going slow or getting cancelled
britain's rail service is on the brink
of failure as much of the country's
infrastructure can't cope with searing
temperatures
makeshift foil used on steel bridges in
an attempt to deflect the heat
road surfaces beginning to melt
more alarming voluntary ambulance staff
trying to back up an already fully
stretched national health service
dealing with heat-related emergencies
and in london if you get out of the sun
and go underground it's even worse
so why is it that britain can't cope
with heat waves so much of it's to do
with its outdated and inadequate
infrastructure you just can't cope with
extreme temperatures
here on london's tube you can't even
have air conditioning the only airflow
is stale
and hot
some passengers can't see what the fuss
is about
35 36 degrees people pay money to go to
places with that and um those places
don't have air conditioning either
yeah so you're basically think it's over
the top yep absolutely
an american tourist isn't impressed it
gets this hot regularly but we have air
conditioning everywhere and everything's
kind of set up for it to be that hot i'm
from philippines so it's the weather is
just fine for me
with the increasing threat of extreme
weather events caused by global warming
many civil engineers believe countries
like the uk need to invest much more the
uk is seeing the impact of climate
change not as much as other countries in
the world and therefore perhaps the
urgency is not felt as much as it should
that they got a big really big task in
hand and they should be
starting on it right now
well now that sense of urgency is
beginning to rise along with the
temperatures setting new records all
across the uk
andrew simmons al jazeera
well uh eleni miravilli is a chief heat
officer of athens in greece uh she joins
us from there thanks for being on the
program uh what do you make of the
difficulties that the uk has been having
in other places
well we've known for
for a while now that uh the
europe has been really suffering from
heat waves in general the
2018 19 20 20 20
20 these were really hot years for
northern for northern and unusually hot
years for northern europe and then 2021
was more in southern europe and now
in 2022 we're seeing again the northern
areas being very affected and the
southern areas being very affected so
um
it's it's it's been um
if i can say a hot spot intern
internationally globally we
we know that climate change affects
different parts of the globe in
different ways and it seems that europe
the mediterranean but also northern
europe has been continuously
been experiencing extraordinary
temperatures uh the last few years a hot
spot indeed so in what measures uh has
athens taken then in order to be more
prepared for increasing heat uh in the
years to come
i'll let you i'll i'll let you know
immediately but but uh yes i'll start
with that so in so
athens has been um what we've been doing
and the way we've been thinking about
responding to heat has been three fold
we are thinking about awareness raising
as a first category then preparedness
actions
and then finally redesign redesigning
the city for heat which is the more long
term and the hardest
as far as awareness raising is concerned
it's an extremely important issue
because somehow even though we are
experiencing extraordinary heat waves it
hasn't really risen to um to policy
levels and to change of behavior levels
among the people so both
the awareness raising and the data
collection and the creation of like
really strong
um
visuals and really strong messages for
how serious heat waves are for human
health as well as ecosystem but as well
as the economies of our countries and
our cities
has to be really
drilled in because
you know we call heat the silent killer
because actually among all other extreme
weather conditions heat is the most is
the one that kills the most people so in
the awareness raising category what
we've done in athens and we did it
together with the city of seville which
has been experiencing extremely hot
temperatures the last week
is
we created the for the first time the
categorization of heat waves and seville
has done also naming and categorizing of
heat waves so we have three different
categories and the categorization is
based on
figuring out in each of these cities
in the past what kind of
heat is actually linked to a jump in the
percentage of uh mortality so we
actually have the effects
within the meteorological category it's
i think it's a very interesting
methodology because especially for
policy makers it's really important to
know
also you know not just the
meteorological data but what is actually
going to be the effect on the people
okay okay so let me just interrupt you
there briefly you mentioned something
about building design in athens can you
be a bit more specific about that
so this is the third thing that i was
going to get to but i'll go directly to
that the
the whole
the second i can go quickly through the
second the second pillar which has to do
with preparedness action short term
things to protect the most vulnerable
which you know we know the most
vulnerable categories and how can we
make sure that we are there present and
doing an early warning specifically for
these people and having ways to check in
on them and provide them with cooler
conditions so this is one i'll quickly
go through that and then finally we have
to redesign our cities and um in athens
this means to a large extent i mean most
cities actually this means to really
radically reintroduce nature in cities
because we do have technologies and we
do have
materials that we can use to lower
temperatures but uh we really need the
best the best shield that we have
against high temperatures is to
create strong um
three um
three canopies uh and healthy tree
canopies as well as bring um
bring water to the to the surface of our
cities and generally really support
biodiversity within the city um
network build networks i mean in in
london you are very lucky because you
have really amazing parks which are
really cooling the city down especially
if you're if you live near them but
a lot of cities around the world do not
have green and blue infrastructure
they've really been building with a lot
of cement and asphalt so
um these are really um absorbing hits
and radiating it especially at night
making it particularly dangerous okay
okay okay i think we're going to have to
leave it there we did get through quite
a lot there so we we very much
appreciate your time eleni maryville
chief heat officer of athens thank you
you're very welcome bye-bye